-All right, welcome back!
Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out a few
thank-you notes right now.
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I get some thank-you-note-
writing music, please?
♪♪
Oh. Beautiful.
-Classic.
-Here we go. [ Clears throat ]
♪♪
Thank you, Peeps,
for being an edible
Mr. Clean Magic Eraser.
-[ Imitating squeaking rubber ]
[ Gags ]
Pbht!
-Actually, I was gonna
blow a bubble.
-Oh. [ Lips pop ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
President Trump and court,
for probably thinking,
"What would Gwyneth do?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I wish you well.
♪♪
-Thank you, green Masters
jackets, for making winners
of the world's
most famous golf tournament
look like they're
assistant managers at Subway.
Is your -- Is your artist
taking care of you?
-[ Chuckles ] Sandwich artists.
-Is your artist
taking care of you?
Yeah.
You work at Subway?
-No, I eat at Subway.
♪♪
-Thank you, canoes,
for being a great way
to travel on the water,
unless you have to shift
your weight one centimeter
to the side, then...
-Oh, oh, hey.
[ Applause ]
-[ Imitates splashing water ]
♪♪
Thank you, vision boards,
for looking like
I'm either a serial killer
or trying to stop
a serial killer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's inside the house.
-He's in the house.
[ Audience chuckles ]
♪♪
-Thank you, candied nuts,
for letting me
get catfished by an almond.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
trying to find the remote,
for being the adult version
of an Easter egg hunt.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.
We'll be right back
with the Jonas Brothers!
-♪ Yeah! ♪